we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us joe
biden is now the seven-year-old kid with
the four-year-old little brother taking
the four-year-old's hand smacking the
four-year-old in the face and going
while you're hitting yourself why are
you hitting yourself
he says you're safe right you're safe
from covet
but then he says you're not safe from
covered so you're safe but not so safe
you're super safe guys the vaccine is
great and it works fantastic also you're
deeply unsafe from your colleagues which
is why we have to restrict all of you
it's why we have to restrict them
they're the bad guys
right we have to we have to make sure
that you don't work as a vaccinated
person next to an unvaccinated person
here's joe biden saying incoherent
nonsense as per his usual routine
the bottom line
we're going to protect vaccinated
workers from unvaccinated co-workers
we're going to reduce the spread of
covet 19 by increasing the share of the
workforce that is vaccinated in
businesses all across america he just
said if you're vaccinated you're safe
now he's saying if you're vaccinated you
have to be protected from your
unvaccinated co-workers again this is
about yelling at people who are not joe
biden
and then he continues to just berate
unvaccinated by the way if you want to
get unvaccinated americans to vaccinate
you know what you don't do you get on tv
you don't get on tv and yell at them
about how dumb they are you try to
convince them you try to actually work
with them you try to get them to go see
a doctor who's going to tell them you
say listen go you're an individual go to
your doctor and ask what's best for you
and let the doctor do the work right
there are things that you can do to
convince unvaccinated americans to get
vaccinated and then there's going to be
a hardcore people who don't want to get
vaccinated and that's their choice that
is their prerogative because as joe
biden says if you are vaccinated you are
safe if you are vaccinated you are safe
that is what the science says but now
we're going to implement policies based
on the precise reverse that if you're
vaccinated you're somehow not safe
okay so again you're just going to yell
more at the unvaccinated it's unreal
my message to unvaccinated americans is
this
what more is there to wait for
what more do you need to see
we've made vaccinations free safe and
convenient
the vaccine is fda approval
over 200 million americans have gotten
at least one shot
we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us
no
it hasn't
it has not it has cost the other
unvaccinated your refusal has i live in
florida you know what the unvaccinated
refusal has has cost me nothing
nothing it hasn't cost me except for
some dictatorial idiots in the
bureaucracy who insist that we mask kids
for no apparent data reason
or some idiot some idiotic bureaucratic
ninis who think that they get to mandate
that you can't go into a business or
something okay and that's their choice
okay that is that is the choice of the
bureaucracy if you don't like the rules
coming from the bureaucrats that's the
fault of the bureaucrats that is not the
fault of the people who live next door
to you who don't think like you do about
the vaccine
the attempt to i keep coming back to
this it is such cowardice it's
unbelievable cowardice here from the
president of the united states and then
he continues along these lines and he
decides he's going to yell at elected
officials right he's going to say it's
not just the unvaccinated that's not the
biggest problem the biggest problem is
also that we have governors governors
who are who are not pushing vaccinations
now i have a question which governor
isn't pushing vaccinations can you name
a single one
ron sanchez has been pushing
vaccinations since day one in fact
there's a 60 minutes article
a 60-minute story about how terrible ron
desantis was such a terrible human being
for vaccinating the elderly first and
getting publics to disseminate the
vaccine
republican governors abbot
lee
gnome desantis they have all been
pushing the vaccine they have all been
saying that you should get the vaccine
okay so it is not about republican
governors not saying you should get the
vaccine every single one has pushed the
vaccine so far as i am aware
it is about the fact that they are not
mandating masks it's about the fact that
they still want you to be able to live
your life which is why their states are
doing better economically speaking than
blue states that joe biden agrees with
so on the one hand he is saying if
you're vaccinated you're safe and if
you're unvaccinated the pandemic applies
to you on the other hand he is saying
damn it these these stupid red state
governors and their unwillingness to
protect the unvaccinated from the other
unvaccinated through mass mandates and
from the vaccinated through mass
mandates you can't have it both ways but
he is wanting to have it both ways so
here he is yelling at governors
what makes it incredibly more
frustrating
is we have the tools to combat covert 19
and a distinct minority of americans
supported by a stink minority of elected
officials are keeping us from turning
the corner
these pandemic politics as i refer to
are
making people sick
causing unvaccinated people to die
we cannot allow these actions
to stand in the way of protecting the
large majority of americans who have
done their part
i want to get back to life as normal
this is
orwellian it's unbelievable he
said okay so he is saying that if you
don't put down a mass mandate you are
causing unvaccinated people to die no
you are not the unvet according to joe
biden himself one second ago okay within
the last second
according to joe biden the unvaccinated
are causing the unvaccinated to die by
not vaccinating
mandating masks isn't causing or failure
to mandate masks is not causing the
unvaccinated to die
the unvaccinated not vaccinating is
causing the unvaccinated to die and when
he says we can't allow these actions to
stand in the way of protecting the
majority of americans who've done their
part and want to get back to life as
normal i've been back to life as normal
since day that i got vaccinated so have
my parents so is everybody else
vaccinated who is not out of their
damned mind the minute you got
vaccinated you were good to go
but according joe biden says that he
says it and then he's still like no no
in order to prevent my authoritarian
mandates we have to go after these
unvaccinated people it's their fault i'm
doing this to you joe biden is now the
seven-year-old kid with the
four-year-old little brother taking the
four-year-old's hand smacking the
four-year-old in the face and going
while you're hitting yourself why are
you hitting yourself
that is who the president of the united
states is he is hitting you
this is his stupid policy it makes no
sense
and and then he continues along these
lines going after other elected
officials
and to make matters worse
there are elected officials
actively working to undermine the fight
against covet 19.
instead of encouraging people to get
vaccinated in a mask up they're ordering
mobile morgues
for the unvaccinated dying from coven in
their communities
this is totally unacceptable who is the
governor who is not urging people to get
vaccinated
notice how he slipped in and mask up
but again why should the vaccinated mask
up to protect the unvaccinated who have
made the choice not to get vaccinated
and we'll get to his policy in a second
because his policy is utterly again
disconnected from constitutional reality
or from enumerated powers basically we
now live under the auspices of an
administrative blob that can do whatever
whatever the hell it wants to you at any
time based on vague authorities granted
to it by a cowardly congress over the
course of the last 50 years that's what
we live under we live under the
dictatorship of the of the bureaucracy
it's it's um the paper pushers run the
country at the behest of old senile men
yelling at you i know what you're
thinking it's time to binge some more
ben shapiro videos well you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video